تمتلك روسيا اكبر عدد من الاسلحه النوويه
النشطه في العالم مع اقوى الصواريخ
الباليستيه وصواريخ الكروز في حين ان
اوكرانيا دوله غير نوويه منذ خروجها من
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق ولد روسيا حوالي
مليون جندي في نطاق الخدمه الفعليه في حين
ان اوكرانيا لديها ربع هذا العدد جويا لدى
روسيا ما يزيد عن
4,600 طائره مقاتله في حين لا يتعدى اسطول
اوكرانيا الجوي
310 طائرات يتكون الاسطول البحري روسي
حاليا من حامله طائرات وخمسه طرادات و23
مدمره وعشرات الفرقاطات والطرادات
والغواصات بينما تمتلك البحريه الاوكرانيه
حاليا فرقاطه واحده وطرادا وعددا قليلا من
سفر الدوريه والسفن المساعده تمتلك القوات
المسلحه الروسيه حاليا حوالي ثلاثه الاف
دبابه قتاليه نشطه غير تلك التي مخازن
بينما تمتلك القوات الاوكرانيه حاليا
قرابه
1900 دبابه عامله بعد عام على الحرب يتحدث
الخبراء العسكريون عن ان روسيا غير قادره
على اعاده تعبئه منظوماتها بالاسلحه باهضه
الثمن بوتيره سريعه لكنها تواصل انتاج
منظومات تقليديه منخفضه الجوده بوتيره
اسرع في المقابل ومع تزايد خسائرها يتناقص
مخزون القوات الاوكرانيه من ناقلات الجند
المدرعه ومركبات المشاه القتاليه
والدبابات بالتزامن مع نقص في قطع الغيار
والذخيره للعديد من منظومات السلاح من
الحقبه السوفيتيه وهو ما تحاول الدول
الغربيه مدها ببدائل لها